[Music]
it will probably take a few more years
until we can finally see Frozen three in
theaters nevertheless several theories
about the plot of the third film are
already circulating even though there is
no footage and no official information
available regardless of whether it's
about a love story reunions you could do
without or spunky surprises the fan
theories truly cover it all in order to
bridge the time until an official
announcement and to fuel your
anticipation a little we have summarized
the best theories for you in today's
original video
before we start we'll briefly recap the
ending of the second part for you so
anyone who doesn't want to hear any
spoilers Should Skip ahead now we will
also quickly go into the individual
character developments between movies 1
and 2. let's be honest there is quite a
bit that should be briefly reviewed Anna
realizes that the only way to free the
Enchanted Forest from the magical mist
is to destroy the dam this was the one
her grandfather had built for the
northoldra on the basis of false
promises although she knew that the
water masses would destroy Arendelle she
got the Earth Giants to tear down the
dam this releases Elsa from her curse
allowing her to escape from Otto Holland
she also finds that she is the fifth
Elemental Spirit which must restore the
balance between the spirits she rides
towards Arendelle as fast as she can on
the enchanted horse knock to save the
city from destruction she is even able
to bring Olaf back to life who
fortunately still retains all of his
memories after all as we have learned
water does have a memory Kristoff also
finally manages to propose to Anna after
two long hours and Elsa realizes that
her future lies not in Arendelle but in
the Enchanted forest with the northoldra
and the spirits so in the end Anna does
become Queen after all
so it can't be said Frozen 2 was more
than just a feast of emotions suspense
feelings jokes everything was provided
especially the character developments in
contrast to the first film were clearly
visible fan favorite Snowman Olaf who
was mostly known for his childish
emotions in the beginning suddenly
starts asking profound questions about
life in Frozen 2 so one could suggest
he's growing up Kristoff is no longer
just the uncouth Iceman instead he grows
into his role as a slightly different
Disney prince he also works hard on his
boyfriend traits and spends 75 percent
of the film figuring out how to propose
to Anna she on the other hand is hardly
recognizable there's not much left of
the naive princess from the first part
rather she is struggling more than ever
to keep her family together and to make
sure that everyone protects each other
in the end it is her who is willing to
make great sacrifices to restore peace
between the spirits now Elsa has to
finally overcome her fear and
acknowledges what she is although she
doesn't even really know that at the
beginning of the film obviously in
search of the truth she comes
increasingly closer to her true destiny
until she finally realizes what she is
at the end thus she can finally leave
the chapter of being a queen behind her
and follow her Destiny last but not
least we still have Sven of course but
what can we say Sven is perfect as he is
because let's face it reindeer are
better than humans anyway
after it took almost two whole movies
for Princess uh we mean Queen Anna to
finally get married fans all across the
internet agree that it's slowly but
surely time for Elsa to find her great
love as well the question that arises
now is of course who do we already know
her future husband and this is exactly
the point where we intervene and say who
is even talking about a future husband
anyone who watched the second part
attentively must have noticed that there
was always a bit of Chemistry Between
Elsa and the northoldra Honey Merit we
would be very happy for the two of them
Elsa actress Idina Menzel also said in
the run-up to the second film that the
relationship between the two reads as if
many things point to a love story in the
third part we all know that love is an
open door still even if Elsa fails to
find the great romance she will
certainly be busy with all sorts of
things in the third installment of the
series after the Mist is lifted and the
Enchanted Forest is now free this
naturally Harbors all sorts of dangers
as seen in part one Arendelle not only
has allies as there are also countries
that look upon the kingdom Within Envy
so it's quite possible that the one or
other villain wants to use the power of
the spirit in order to plunge Arendelle
into chaos again although needless to
say they would have to get past Elsa
first but not only are there dangers
lurking from the outside in the past
many people from Arendelle itself were
reluctant if not distrustful of magic
above all Anna and Elsa's grandfather
King rooneyard therefore it would be
reasonable to think that there could be
another plot against the northoldra and
the spirits of the forest which must be
thwarted by Elsa
Elsa now known as the snow queen after
part 1 is renowned as being capable of
turning anything into ice but what about
Anna does she really have no more Powers
Beyond her courage and willingness to
give her all for the ones she loves fans
of the internet aren't sure and an
increasing number of rumors suggests
that Anna learns she can control fire
hints about this can be found in the
film if you search for it the most
obvious one is of course that her sister
possesses Powers moreover Anna herself
has red hair the color of fire for
example whereas Elsa has white hair
matching her ice powers yet the
character traits of each also match
their abilities while Elsa seems rather
calm reserved and a tad cold Anna is
consistently hyperactive wild and
Unstoppable a conceivable scenario would
be that Anna acquires her abilities and
is unable to cope with the destructive
nature of fire much like her sister in
part one Elsa must then rush to the
rescue and help her deal with the power
of her newly acquired Talent absolutely
a scenario that we would find more than
just exciting
a rumor that is spreading through the
internet but that everyone hopes is not
true is the return of Hans you guys
don't remember exactly who Hans is well
it's understandable that you forget
about that little creature so we're
gonna jog your memory one more time he
is the youngest of 12 brothers from the
royal family of the Southern Islands
recognizing that he will never amount to
anything in life he tries to overthrow
Elsa in fact he almost succeeds in doing
so by pretending to love Anna who was
still very naive at the time he will
surely not be able to enter Arendelle
simply like that again but with the
Enchanted Forest a whole new world has
opened up for him it would be
conceivable that he would like to get
hold of the forest similar to the
kingdom besides it would not be totally
out of the question that he might try
his luck with Arendelle once again now
that the mighty Elsa is no longer Queen
perhaps with the help of his brothers or
possibly with an army
at the end of Frozen 2 there is much
talk about Anna's big day but it quickly
becomes clear that this is not about her
marriage to Christoph rather it's about
her coronation so it remains to be seen
whether the two have even gotten married
yet if they haven't we really hope to
see their wedding in the third part not
only since they aren't the typical
Disney couple but also because the
wedding could be the focus of a larger
story what if Hans came and kidnapped
Anna Olaf's fan Kristoff and Elsa would
then have to go looking for her in order
to rescue her possibly Sven and Kristoff
would crash on one of their tours
although that would be a little too
lackadaisical for a Frozen part for sure
no matter how the story surrounding the
royal wedding might turn out it is clear
that we absolutely want to see it the
only royal wedding that we would
actually watch in theaters
one perspective focuses on the narrative
where the two sisters are satisfied
where they are with Anna as Queen of
Arendelle and Elsa with the northoldra
folks in the forest so it could make
sense to concentrate more on Kristoff
who may be left with some baggage to
unload for instance contemplate his
parents mystery Kristoff is the initial
main character we probably encounter in
Frozen and he emerges as a boy we
actually see him being kidnapped by
trolls the assumption is that he is
orphaned with no relatives until he is
taken care of by the Fantastical beings
but what if christoph's folks are still
living somewhere and return to find
their son married into the royal family
so far the films have always focused on
the protagonists overcoming past
problems in order to build a brighter
life for example Kristoff finding his
parents and forming a bond with them
will remain there are numerous
Alternatives here for one aspect it
could start playing into the
quintessential trolls are actually
Wicked Theory particularly since it's
discovered they kidnapped Kristoff from
his parents as a kid but what could be
the reason behind that this Theory would
investigate christoph's past and bring
him some peace to live his present
another Frozen 3 Theory suggests that
there will be an antagonist situation
hence strongly implying that Warfare is
a real possibility the potential is that
a different Kingdom will attempt to try
to invade and occupy the Enchanted
Forest forcing Arendelle to intervene
militarily on their account a monstrous
enemy will be actually presented will be
incredibly difficult to beat even with
Elsa's skills and knowledge this
villain's henchman could potentially
conduct Warfare against all of Arendelle
it is possible that they will Journey to
the middle of the desert or tropical
country to discover more about this
super villain as winter and Autumn have
already been covered in the previous
movies it would indeed be fun to see
Elsa and Anna in a different environment
and also to comprehend how helpful and
effective Elsa's powers are in such a
type of environment
though not only Anna and Elsa could be
made the focus of the event many fans
would certainly also be happy about a
prequel to The Snow Queen Series in
which the adventures of their parents
are illuminated in more detail the story
around king agnar and queen aduna is
capable of filling more than just one
movie now that we know how the two met
many questions remain unanswered what
happened to aduna after the catastrophe
in the Enchanted Forest she surely did
not stay at the Royal Court so how did
she grow up after what happened her life
as northoldra must not have been easy in
Arendelle on the other hand it would
also continue to be exciting around
agnar after all he became king overnight
and he was still a young boy without a
father the first years of his Regency
would provide suspense on the screen for
sure finally their love story could be
told which would surely be almost as
thrilling as that of their daughter
though there are plenty of other
characters from Frozen that have
exciting stories as well Lieutenant
Dustin Matthias for example many people
would surely be interested in what
became of the soldiers from Arendelle
after they were trapped in the mist or
what the life of loyal Matthias was like
before the disaster not only him but
also Olaf yelana the trolls Oaken and
Sven all of these characters have
potential to fill a film in which the
Two Sisters would at best play a
supporting role
so that was it our theories for a
possible Frozen three which ideas
appealed to you the most or do you even
have one that we didn't take up at all
let us know in the comments down below
if you liked the video then be sure to
give it a thumbs up apart from that it's
just a matter of time until we finally
get our hands on some official
information see you next time
[Music]
thank you